le bilan est lourd au moins 6 personnes
manquaient appel à la suite de
l'incendie de l'immeuble Place
d'Youville Camille Maheu 70 ans est
introuvable
était nulle part on le cherchait
beaucoup on la cherche à regarder les
proches de Charlie Lacroix 18 ans sont
venus lui laisser des fleurs toute sa
famille
on s'est mis ensemble pour éviter bye
bye
le grand-père de Charlie Lacroix
explique que sa petite fille était dans
un logement loué sur Airbnb
disait nous chercher parce qu'il y a pas
de fenêtre ce qu'on dit 3 minutes plus
tard le 9h reçoit un second appel de
détresse le téléphone a coupé
des appartements où il y a aucun accès
que la porte les locations à court terme
sont illégales dans le secteur du Vieux
Montréal et le 224 Place d'Youville
n'avait pas de certificat d'examption
pour pouvoir le faire Alina couz Mina
louait elle aussi Airbnb cette soirée-là
l'avertisseur de fumée ne s'est jamais
déclenchée
14 logements résidentiels le
propriétaire de l'édifice n'a pas
répondu à nos demandes d'entrevue
ont changé règlement d'autant plus ça
fait des plusieurs diamants qu'on fait à
Québec par Revenu Québec pour nous aider
au niveau de l'inspection pour l'instant
la structure de l'édifice est trop
instable pour y entrer une équipe qui
est en train de préparer notre plan
d'intervention il y a plus d'urgence
comme tel pour le moment lorsqu'il faut
s'assurer c'est la sécurité des
intervenants une fois l'édifice
sécurisés les recherches des disparus
pourront commencer ici marie-abelle
Rochon Radio-Canada Montréal